wehrheim bricht alle rekorde mit 1200
kilometern pro stunde dollar zwischen
metropol verkehren das hat ist man zum
beispiel von berlin in köln schon jetzt
instituts strecke in den rap kurz vor
der fertigstellung und die erste strecke
in dubai wird konkret geplant und auch
in deutschland wird jetzt über eine
hyper loop strecke nachgedacht als
ersatz für den innerdeutschen
flugverkehr die lufthansa hat interesse
bekundet das ist wirklich sensationell
das neueste zum heimflug natürlich hier
bei krieg zum zwischen wissenschaft und
technik täglich herzlich willkommen der
transrapid brauchte 43 jahre wie wir
erstmal menschen im regelbetrieb
transportierte 2002 wurde die erste
kommerzielle strecke der magnetbahn in
china eingeweiht aber er ist in jeder
hinsicht ein misserfolg zu laut zu
hässlich und verbraucht so viel strom
die folgen er verkehrt mit nur wenigen
passagieren fährt nur so schnell wie ein
ece weil der strom sonst zu teuer wäre
und er wird nicht weiter gebaut und das
bei einer so vielversprechenden
technologie kann beim prolog soll das
jetzt anders sein die idee ist auch viel
einfacher und ziemlich genial und solche
ideen machen auf den unterschied aus
manchmal ist es wirklich frappierender
forschen teams jahrzehntelang an einer
technologie und dann hat einer eine idee
die den unterschied macht und zum
mittels los beim hyper look scheint der
fall zu sein
dabei ist die idee wirklich super
einfach rohrpost und die könnte der
magnetschwebebahn technik jetzt im
nachhinein zum erfolg verhelfen des
prinzips der zug oder beim heimklub eine
kapsel wird in eine röhre gepackt und in
der erst ein vakuum bzw
ist kaum noch luft enthalten ein
sogenanntes teil vakuum
hochleistungspumpen pumpen die luft aus
der röhre und erhalten dieses teil
vakuum der effekt es gibt praktisch
keinen luftwiderstand mehr das
hauptproblem und der energiefresser
jedes schnellen transport es ist einfach
weg wow
damit brauche ich für den zug kaum noch
also für die fortbewegung kaum noch
energie ist bei einmal beschleunigt es
sollen solarzellen auf den
transporteuren ausreichen um für die
energie zu sorgen und eine neue
magnetschwebetechnik ist geplant bei der
deutlich weniger energie verbraucht wird
permanentmagneten die im sogenannten
halbach angeordnet sind sollen zum einen
die magnetkraft
die kapsel nahezu auf null reduzieren
wichtig zum beispiel für träger von
herzschrittmachern und im gegenzug unten
zum transport track verstärken in dem
track heißt die technik die von luk
transportation technologies angewendet
wird dabei gibt es noch ein weiteres
unternehmen das freibad in die realität
umsetzen will
heike luckmann in maskat die technischen
prinzipien nämlich zu open source
erklärte jeder kann auf der grundlage
seiner technologie hyper loop
weiterentwickeln damit ist ein wettlauf
entstanden der offenbar richtig tempo
bei der entwicklung bringt und wenn man
den vielen presseveröffentlichungen
glaubt dann geht es so richtig voran
heiner lohmann ist kurz vor der
fertigstellung einer teststrecke des
flug nach las vegas in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten haben die planung
für die erste strecke zwischen dubai und
abu dhabi begonnen und jetzt soll sich
auch die lufthansa für das projekt
interessieren wie könnte sich vorstellen
strecke zwischen köln berlin berlin
münchen hamburg münchen und düsseldorf
münchen mit hyperdoc zu betreiben ein
großteil des deutschen luftverkehrs
würde so ersetzt werden durch eine viel
umweltfreundlichere technologie und
zusätzlich sollte ein produkt auf der
strecke doppelt so schnell sein hier ein
flugzeug
ich bin mal extrem gespannt ob und wie
schnell das konzept umgesetzt werden
kann es gibt auch zahlreiche skeptiker
wie mein zu schwierig zu teuer aber vor
allem die bürokratischen hürden könnten
extrem sei allerdings hat der heimflug
einen extremen vorteil und das finde ich
richtig toll es ist keine nationale
technologie jeder darf einbauen egal ob
amerikaner deutscher oder chinese das
dass sie die hürden zur realisierung
deutlich sehen mehr über die
verkehrsmittel der zukunft gibt es
übrigens hier
und zwar darüber wie jeder von uns mal
in den weltraum reisen dann einfach
draufklicken wobei jeder es wird
wahrscheinlich ein bild oft wenig kosten
wenn er kein video mehr verpassen wollt
dann sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge
einfach draufhauen ekligen und vergessen
ich mir dann noch einen auf die glocke
zu geben ansonsten bis dann bleibt